[Music]
the mansion where angie is making her
new home is spectacular and just a mile
and a half from Kim McConaughey's digs
it's big over 8,000 square feet listed
for sale at almost 7 million and renting
for up to $30,000 a month the kitchen
love it there's two beach entry pools
with the cascading waterfall a Cabana
even a teepee for the grown-ups there's
a gourmet kitchen and a wine tasting
room and also top-notch are the new
additions to Julie's legal dream team
joining Laura Wasser who's famous
clients include Johnny Depp is
reportedly Pierce O'Donnell who is
wrapped Johnny's ex Amber Heard along
with Steven Spielberg and several
studios he's been called one of the 100
most influential Lawyers in America
and also now on the Joely team Hollywood
heavyweight Bert field his clients have
included Michael Jackson George Harrison
and Tom Cruise for Tom he's taken on
several tabloids for libel when people
do things that cross the line they
really ought to be punished as for Angie
he told us in a letter quote what is
that stake here is the health welfare
and safety of six minor children their
protection is the only issue about which
Angelina is concerned
[Music]